[Music]
the new england patriots won their sixth
super bowl to cap the 2018 season we are
going to take a look right now at their
off season so far we're gonna do that
with every team in the coming weeks
today patriots and cardinals i guess
from the top all the way down to the
bottom but at the top you know chris
when you consider all the changes have
happened to the patriots this year and
they have had plenty of key departures
they have added a bunch of players we
would look at any other team and say oh
my god what are they going to do but
because the page was like oh don't worry
about it they have a plan chris hogan
gone gronk retired well that's fine
trent brown signs the raiders that's
fine trey flower has gone fine quarter
pasting on fire it's fine they're fine
because it's the patriots any other team
we'd be like what the hell are they
gonna do patriots they're gonna continue
to find a way to get it done yeah well
and i think some of the positions you're
talking about i mean new england has
like a farm system of these type of
players i mean the guys like trey
flowers offensive linemen this is the
great thing about new england you know
when you look at their roster right now
they have a ton of those type of
football players so you know again i
think the thing that jumps out to me
more than anything with new england is
their smart off season approach they
never overpay for their own football
players they never really overpay for
anybody in free agency really in recent
history let's think about it i'm being
serious here other than stefan gilmour
right is there anybody that they've
really paid big money to and that's
because dalias thomas right and that was
what two years ago 13 years ago so it
just shows you how they believe in
building a football team it's about
quality buys and free agency and then
building through the draft and i thought
they had quite quietly had a very good
draft as well with a lot of new england
type of guys right chase vinovich in the
third round they get jared stidham in
the fourth round might be the
replacement to tom brady and then you
know in in the first round they get a
nikhil harry who i think is going to
take away some of that pressure of gronk
down the middle and maybe losing a chris
hogan and know danny amendola there so i
i'm with you yes it's not always sexy
with the patriots but it's still the
patriots and they have a plan
and i trust it and they've made a lot of
correct moves i think overall for their
football team
during the segment that we did on tv
during the radio break we were musing
about the possibility that gronk could
come back at some point this year and we
consider the tight end position yeah
gronk is retired dwayne allen was cut
they added austin safrari and jenkins
they didn't draft the tight end they
traded jacob hollister last week right
to the seahawks for a conditional
seventh round pick which means he wasn't
going to be around anyway if he wasn't
traded you just have to wonder whether
that is a move that gets made or if it's
not gronk coming back and this would
maybe slam the door on a gronk on
retirement that possibility of a you
know the vikings have made it very clear
that kyle rudolph is available without
coming out and saying we have no intent
to trade kyle rudolph they have made it
clear that kyle rudolph is available
right and if that move would happen that
that addresses the tight end position i
now look i don't know that kyle rudolph
would immediately assimilate to the
patriot way because it's not something
for everyone but you know that's the one
glaring hole that i see when that's been
such a key part of the offense over the
years who's going to step in and do that
and maybe they see something in austin
safari and jenkins we don't and they've
faced him enough times that they know
what he's got maybe he comes in and has
a career here in that offense yeah i i
don't doubt that you know i never doubt
that just the way they're coached up in
new england they're you know that's the
great thing about not only belichick the
assistants they're so into every nuance
of the game every technique players get
better there yeah sometimes players go
there and we don't hear from them again
because they wilt under the you know
everyday pressure of the new england
patriots and the work ethic but other
guys coming there sometimes who are
willing to take coaching and thrive and
then we go who the hell is this guy what
happened who is he how come he's good on
the patriots why is he good on the
patriots because the patriots put him in
positions to succeed always they
realistically know what the guy's
talents are and they have coaches that
get the most out of it that's why that
happens in new england now with the
tight end play like you said yes it is
an issue on their football team you know
kyle rudolph certainly on the radar i
think that would be like plan c maybe
down the way i think first ben watson
that would be the first name i would
look at you know you know it looked like
he might retire it was all done but
started his career in new england i
certainly could see him maybe making one
more last splash and going to the
patriots but they're going to kick the
can on some of the guys you mentioned
the first i mean austin safarian jenkins
he's got some talent he's had some off
the field issues maturing issues i think
they think well maybe we can make
something and then guys like matt
lacoste who they got from denver last
year and stephen anderson new england's
the king of finding you know you know
diamonds in the rough right to where
they're going to kick the tires on some
of these guys and see if they can't make
something of them first before they
start exhausting the you know lifelines
of what's called the minnesota vikings
and kyle rudolph
ben watson won a super bowl ring in 2004
with the patriots as a rookie he played
in one game
that year he has won no super bowls
since then he's been around for so long
we just assumed that he's got a handful
of rings no he's been playing for teams
that haven't been in super bowl
contention and the possibility of him
unretiring and coming back i you know at
a time we're thinking about gronk
unretiring and coming back maybe it's
ben watson who unretires and comes back
but that's clearly an area of need and
you mentioned keele harry first round
pick on a receiver for the first time
since 1996 when they took terry glenn i
don't think bill belichick is rolling
the dice on this guy unless he
senses something special about and kiel
harry because
they've been able to put together this
patchwork of receivers over the years
without making the big investment of a
first-round pick except when they traded
a first-round pick to get brandon cooks
but then they flipped him for a first
round pick a couple of years after that
but this one intrigues me because look
as tom brady gets older maybe you maybe
you need something better than just
whatever guys happen to be hanging
around the football field to come out
and catch passes from it yeah i think
that's a valid point along with they
they just need the position they need a
difference maker there needs somebody
there that you know like a gronk you
know when someone when everybody's
covered who can tom throw to do with the
get out of jail free card and nikhil
harry's that type of guy you know other
than julian edelman who's going to be
that guy that when when brady throws the
ball five yards over the middle of the
field who can make it into a 15 or a 20
yard gain that's the questions we have
about new england and the and the pass
catching department and then kill harry
brings that big time mike i think he's
gonna be a lot like a michael thomas or
the new orleans saints not a guy that
you line up outside and go oh we're
going to throw bombs down the field all
day long no when he's outside it's going
to be underneath routes it's going to be
back shoulder you know 50 50 jump balls
that stuff but i think more his bread
and butter is gonna be over the middle
of the field he's amazing with the ball
in his hand the first guy cannot tackle
this guy he's physical and he can break
ankles and i think that's the beauty of
what he brings to the offense
and i think this is the key with gronk
gone right he's the guy that would
command that double coverage he's the
guy that would screw up the game sure
you need someone else to do it because
it can't be julian edelman julian
edelman is knock if you've doubled
julian edelman you are taking him out of
the game right yeah so you need someone
on the outside that is getting the help
over the top so edelman can keep doing
his thing underneath like he did when
gronk was there i think that's the real
reason they've gotten keel harry so
julian edelman continues to be julian
adam
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports